[Music]
hi I'm Michelle gelfan I'm a professor
of organizational behavior at the
Stanford Graduate School of Business one
of my favorite classes to teach at the
GSB is
negotiation even though negotiations are
pervasive research shows that we often
leave value at the table I have five key
takeaways from my class on negotiation
to share with you
[Music]
today
preparation is a vital part of the
negotiation process yet many people fail
to properly analyze their own and others
perspectives prior to discussions I
recommend that you create an issue chart
and spend time thinking through your own
interest and goals your priorities your
Alternatives and your strengths and your
weaknesses and then do the same for your
partner the more complete the
information you have about yourself and
your partner the more control you'll
have over your actions reactions during
the process and the better able you'll
be to craft great agreements if you
don't prepare you're putting yourself at
a disadvantage and likely will leave
value at the table as you negotiate ask
questions to try to fill in gaps in the
information you have and test the
assumptions that you
[Music]
made metaphors are a basic mechanism
through which humans conceptualize
experience including negotiations
metaphors are more than linguistic
devices that can help or hinder
negotiations
yet we're often completely unaware of
the metaphors guiding us at the
negotiation table is this an individual
or a team sport a battle a dance a date
a puzzle a visit to the dentist or
necessary evil metaphors guide our goals
our behavioral scripts and the criteria
we use to evaluate the success of the
negotiation but a lot of time our
metaphors are not well match to the
situation a relationship metaphor for
example is not well matched to a
Distributive single issue task on the
other hand a game or battle metaphor is
not well matched to an integrative
negotiation think more clearly about
your metaphors and you'll be a better
negotiator the best negotiators also
cultivate a shared constructive metaphor
to guide the process a problem solving
metaphor like solving a puzzle or
playing on the same team in other words
negotiate the negotiation generate a
shared metaphor to guide the process and
it will be more
productive
research has shown that negotiators
often assume that their interests are
diametrically opposed to their
counterparts although some issues might
be win lose many negotiations have an
integrative structure wherein there can
be differences and priorities
individuals have on the issues that
could be traded off for example imagine
that my husband and I are trying to plan
a vacation I want to go to the spa at
the beach oras he wants to go to a cabin
in the mountains at first glance it
seems like we're going to go on
different vacations but through further
discussion we discover that my priority
is the spa and the location is a lower
priority whereas he prioritizes the
mountains and the accommodations are a
lower priority by trading off on low
priority issues and going to a spa in
the mountains we each get our priorities
when negotiating think outside the box
the best negotiators are very
creative disputes are rejected CL claims
are inevitable but there is a way to
manage them effectively research finds
that people tend to reciprocate negative
behaviors like threats to a much greater
extent than positive strategies causing
conflicts to escalate rapidly in an
unproductive negotiation people use a
lot of threats and appeals to their
rights and don't Focus as much on their
underlying interests in an effective
system people focus a lot on interest
and use very few appeals to power and
rights always aim at getting back to
your interests even in the face of
threats and power strategies from others
if others are using rights and power
strategies a mixed communication
strategy that combines a threat with a
Cooperative communication and appeal to
interests will help you better manage
[Music]
disputes in today's Global
interdependent world we are bound to be
negotiating across cultural boundaries
but people often assume that what works
in their own culture works everywhere
the mistake think that it's technical
competence and general intelligence that
are needed to Be an Effective negotiator
but in a global negotiation it's
cultural intelligence that's key to
mastering the deal cultural differences
if not properly managed can derail
merges and Acquisitions expatriate
assignments and damage our Global
Capital High CQ is also critical for
managing Global teams being an effective
gold leader and managing complex
crosscultural networks Beyond IQ or even
EQ research shows that if you cultivate
cultural intelligence the desire and
ability to interact across cultures
you'll be in a much better position to
develop high quality agreements anywhere
around the world
[Music]
ciao my kids think that it's fun to make
fun of me that I like to create win-win
agreements all the time you know really
Mom do we have to always create win-win
agreements and can't we just split the
difference you know they have a point
sometimes we don't have enough time or
things are not important to you you
don't need to create a women agreement
you can just split the difference but
they do make fun of me being a little
bit obsessed with win-win
[Music]
agreements